hi there Steve Kaufman here again was a
lovely day here in Vancouver I actually
played some golf with my wife we had a
lovely dinner and what I'd like to talk
about now is something that relates to a
recent blog post where I talked about a
gentleman called John Taylor get old and
John Taylor Gatto is a very bitter I
would have to call him critic of public
schooling and he and I put a number of
his quotes on my on my blog the linguist
on language and I think some of his
criticisms of schooling are quite
appropriate and he talks about the cost
of school public school and it's I don't
know what it is ten thousand dollars per
person per year there's 25 kids in a
classroom so that classroom is costing
250 thousand dollars every year for nine
months that's an awful lot of money for
very very limited results I think there
are all kinds of options to that and I
believe that the ipad is is going to be
one of the ways in which the the
monopoly control that the school system
exercises will be challenged and that
people will have more choice but and so
I think those are all very positive
things and by that and I agree with John
Taylor Gatto in a lot of his criticisms
of public schooling where I don't agree
is where he sort of attacks modern
society he seems to claim that that
schooling making kids sit in the
classroom is is really just an
opportunity to train them to be good
workers so that they can work in
factories or in offices
and that they'll be docile citizens and
that somehow there was this other age
and in his interviews that isn't too he
talks about Monongahela or some place in
Pennsylvania which was such a wonderful
place yeah but the fact is mostly people
worked in a steel mill and that
everybody there was such a good person
and nowadays people are disconnected
from each other and from anything that
matters and so forth and there was just
some kind of golden age out there before
schooling when people had better values
and stuff and you know I was also
listening on my favorite source of
Russian learning which is echamos fee
and they interviewed robert bateman who
is a very famous canadian painter and he
also said that he wants as a teacher
worked in nigeria and he was a teacher
in a small village and everybody in the
village was very happy that they didn't
have much but they were happy but when
they went to the city then they became
unhappy so this whole idea that people
who live in primitive circumstances
whether in a village in africa or three
four hundred years ago that those people
were happier um you know obviously I
have not lived in an African village I
didn't live three four hundred years ago
I don't know how happy those people were
but what I do know is that the people
who live in African villages want
desperately to move to the cities
because in the cities there's work and
in the cities there's an opportunity to
earn money and to buy things and those
people are not necessarily people who
have been corrupted by our certainly not
by our North American education system I
know that in the 17th century the
average and the 18
tree and for much of the 19th century
the average life expectancy was 30 to 40
years there was no transportation you
couldn't it was very difficult to go
anywhere and if you had a bumper crop in
your area it would rot because you
couldn't store it and you couldn't move
it to those areas where they didn't have
a bumper crop and where they start
because they had a poor crop I know that
in those days the conspicuous
consumption and this is another thing
that people complain about is the
consumerism in our society I say
consumerism is good it means people have
a choice they can choose what they want
to buy and very often they have the
means now unfortunately some people to
choose to consume beyond their means but
this again is their choice but back in
the 17th century eighty ninety percent
of the people who lived on the land had
no choice they got to keep a percentage
of the harvest the land owner nobleman
took the rest the state you know king
Louis the fourteenth or whatever or
Kaiser Franz Joseph or whoever it might
have been they gobbled up all the money
through taxation they were the only
consumers in a modern sense they had
servants they bought the luxury goods
and today we have an opportunity to buy
a variety of goods that they could not
have dreamed up besides which we live to
70 or 80 years even in poor countries so
that's not to say that there aren't
problems today but to suggest that in
some golden era in the olden days people
who are better off I don't believe it
and I also don't believe this whole
thing about how we you know we're
cutting down all the trees and we're
polluting the air and stuff if you read
about London or other
European cities in the seventeenth and
eighteenth century sanitary conditions
were much worse than they are today and
people died of all kinds of diseases
today yeah there are issues there are
issues with pollution there is the issue
of of the non-renewable resources that
we're depleting I happen to believe that
we will find technical solutions and
that the only way to get out of this
conundrum is through technology which
will either reduce our consumption of
non renewables or we'll find substitute
you know energy resources or we'll find
more of the same but my hope is that we
will find a way to not deplete the world
of non-renewable resources but there are
seven billion people or close to that
number alive today in the good old days
there were barely a billion and that's a
lot of people who have been given the
gift of life and most of those people
live better today and longer and
healthier and they're more literate they
read more they're more aware of things I
mean life is infinitely better today
than it was 100 or 200 years ago in my
view and I think that the you know with
this whole global warming thing is very
fashionable to knock the West you know
industrialization and stuff but that's
what has brought us this improvement in
our living standard so i am not a fan of
everything was great many hundreds of
years ago but i do think as john taylor
Garrow points out that there are
problems with our education system and
that the idea that you
spend ten thousand dollars per child per
year and then you have no choice I
believe that we are going to be
witnessing the same kind of revolution
that took place on the land where we
used to be ninety percent of the people
on the land where we had no choice and
the Lord's and the nobility and the
Kings decided everything we're going to
have more choice and I believe strangely
perhaps that the ipod ipad this idea of
an electronic tablet where you can be
connected anywhere and at any time that
this is the key to getting rid of the
monopoly control of education that the
public education system has and the
public teachers unions have and all of
these monolithic organizations that tell
everybody what to learn how to learn etc
and regt them that this is going to come
unwrapped become unraveled and I think
the ipad ipad is going to be a big part
of it and i'm going to be talking about
that more over the next at a while so
thank you for listening bye for now